in his job as a window cleaner Lars
nickel gets to meet all sorts of people
Nicola is actually a photographer by
profession and has turned his lens on
many of his clients the only thing his
subjects have in common is that they can
all afford a window cleaner hemet is it
in potty but again my works are
portraits with the added dimension that
they offer a tiny view into the subjects
homes finna didn't call it voyeuristic
and my aim isn't just to show how people
live or decorate their space I just
enjoy the interplay that's one for beer
but who wouldn't be curious to see what
it looks like behind the windows of
Berlin Lars nickel has somewhere between
two and three hundred clients scattered
across the city he usually cleans their
windows twice a years
nicol came up with the idea for his
sideline profession seven years ago when
he realized he couldn't make ends meet
as a photographer
it puts our hope tightly in privados hi
I mainly clean windows for private
individuals because that's a niche
that's not addressed by the larger
companies from even when I clean windows
in private hands I also develop personal
relationships that's a good for my photo
project and it makes for pleasant
working conditions for my photo Poyet
vegetation under doesn't an oniony move
at our weddin nickel uses an analog roll
film camera and natural light that
allows him to set up his camera almost
anywhere he chooses he takes about five
or ten pictures each time that's all he
needs about two-thirds of his clients
say yes to having a portrait taken along
with their window cleaning who asks why
ines ides you're in a familiar
environment which does help it's but
it's still completely unfamiliar
situation when the furthest you've let a
stranger into your apartment and you're
just standing there suddenly you ask
yourself what is he seeing anyhow what's
behind me and what am I revealing about
the place that I live in from my na
hoona
Nichols photos have also been published
as a book something that probably
surprised some of his subjects what a
berlin-based publishers snapped up the
project Minato salertisch you went on
fiah see young hip couples from the mid
to district you know the kind a lot of
thumbs right next to a contented retiree
from charlottenburg who is reliving her
memories from dilcia they're connected
by the fact that they live somewhere
happen to know each other but they're
living spaces are as different as the
people themselves not reach the window
sheet EG dimensional lars nickel chose
80 portraits for his photo volume it's
titled bella taj the book also includes
short profiles of his subjects
doesn't he mama wasn't then slower back
when this is a midwife from the
prenzlauer berg district and it's one of
my favorite pictures because it fits so
well with the title Bella tahj with the
furnishings and the picture frame and
the picture itself which likely dates
from the will him in genera photo roster
for Malaysian resource that will not say
last year Nicole was even invited to
exhibit his portraits at the deutsches
haus at New York University
each loved as a developer he knows as is
unless it's also a portrait of Berlin a
contemporary portrait of Germany and how
people furnish their homes it's probably
a bit different than how it would look
in poznan or Warsaw for example were and
of course in the other direction in
Paris or London people furnish their
homes differently too and as I
envisioned even with one book under his
belt Mars nickel cannot afford to give
up his day job but he's still happy that
his clients and the world have been
given the chance to see that he's not
only a reliable window cleaner he's also
an artist